joseph je te présente la femme
nouvellement bienvenue dans ma modeste
officines aussi loin que porte ton
regard dit que choisir ce que tu donnes
c'est pour toi tais toi non c'est pour
toi c'est pour moi et joseph et moi qui
te feront tazi trempe rang des crèmes
prend des brosses à dents des pompes
d'avenant n'hésitez pas je mets ça sur
sa note on a l'habitude la production de
graines de tous côtés par hasard elodie
bons trucs et le viagra est bien le
viagra
bah écoute on en a évidemment donc emma
richard et bien on prend médecine voulez
vous amuser avec ça c'est un autre
blogueur non pas du tout on sait juste
que l'intérêt ce point de vue aussi créé
une fois ceci alors deux mois une boîte
j'ai besoin c'est dire combien de temps
on sature 12h 12h30 ça mais j'ai envie
d'essayer parce qu'il paraît que c'est
une vraiment est le sésame marche c'est
cela la fleur au fusil quoi faut-il
trouver dans la rue famelart que le mois
et tu sais qu'elle est à nouveau qu'ils
ont grossi s'appelle viazac levier sachs
la mélanger à gré avec transats et
savais que tu bandes plus que tu t'en
fous mais pas cette fois ci nos
prétendus viendra essayer